well we have our prodigal son I have at
home he was Alex here who is key part of
our team marketing customer support
ideas going forward you name it
donkey you know donkey yes and fluent
Korean speaker and you were just in
Korea and how I was oh it was great I
was there for two weeks
um I got back two days ago something
still very jet-lagged at this point but
it was great I mean it was my sixth time
to Korea so we've been there quite a few
times and I have I mean I have a pretty
good thing going where you know my
Korean level is quite good I think you
know I can get around quite easily in
Korea not perfect I mean there's still
plenty of room to grow I'm reminded of
that every day but I also have had the
opportunity in my travels to Korea to
meet quite a few different people and so
for me it's great because I can go there
and I can hang out with friends that I
know okay maybe once a year so let me
ask you a few questions about your life
so you say you're and I've heard you and
you to me you sound totally fluent but
that's because I'm not a Korean speaking
so if you go in a store does it ever
happen that people say stuff to you that
you don't understand um yeah I mean
there we'll put it this way
in an average store no right but for
instance on my second-to-last day I went
into a yaku which is like a pharmacy and
advice they have them all over Korea way
more than they have from here right but
they're they have random different
things as well my mom had wanted like a
hot pack you basically put it in the
microwave heated up it's this thing
called ginger pack so I found out that
they sold them here so I go in and I at
and I'm looking to buy one the person in
front of me
is asking about some sort of medicine
and that the attendant there says you
need a whole bottle for this and I don't
I didn't know the word Toba I was like
okay
never heard this word before but they're
talking a bit more and she keeps
insisting well you need this towba and
I'm always brother sounds I feel like
it's a prescription I'm not sure but
that's what I think and so when I left
the store and I asked God whatever I
needed a life the store checked it out
on the dictionary and I'm like oh that's
what that means but I definitely do I
mean there so it would be missing bits
of vocab yes okay
newspaper problem newspaper I mean the
the biggest difficulty for me now is the
more advanced words that come from
Chinese right what I find is that those
don't come across very often in everyday
conversation or regular writing
communication between people it's more
in kind of formal settings that that
language is used right and I find that
there is much bigger of a distinction
between that in Korean between you know
casual and informal language than there
is in say English between talking to
friends right and writing in academic
papers okay so I still struggle a lot
with some did you when you were there
did you do anything specific in so far
as working on some aspect of your Korean
or you were just there to have fun um
yeah I mean I'm always looking to
improve my Korean this time around what
I really have noticed recently is as one
of my weak points is my reading speed in
Korean because he uses a different
alphabet so I just find that there's
always a struggle for me if I see
something in Korean I can probably
understand it but it's just that mental
effort that's required to actually
process the words right so I made a much
more significant effort this time around
to try and read more read more books you
know read more stuff that I see read
more articles on my phone and stuff like
that
have you read books like Frank carbon
cover I've read some not a lot what I
find is that I mean I don't really read
that many books in English but I do a
lot of reading in English so I've read
countless Artic
countless blog post that is the vast
majority of my reading right but yeah I
tried to that was probably my main focus
is to try and like read more and I think
as you read more you learn more
vocabulary so I'm trying to make that
effort because for me speaking and
listening and stuff is easy and stuff I
do all the time it comes much more
easily or a sitting down with a book and
actually concentrating on it that's the
challenge so that was my another
question if you are with people or
you're in a room where there are Koreans
and their conversation is flying back
and forth between these Koreans are you
quite comfortable to yuria because
that's always difficult to it oh yeah
so how good are you at picking up that
third party conversation I'm a lot
better now I'm quite comfortable now I'm
not as good as a native in that scenario
but I can definitely hold my own weight
in a conversation that's happening
between a group of people but I remember
in the early days like that was that was
the worst thing because you sit there in
a group of people and you understand
nothing and you sit there and you were
just looking blankly and you know like
you either
know just to give me some words of
encouragement how many years before I
would be able to pick up second third
party conversation so um I think for me
it's really come with a lot of direct
exposure to that kind of scenario right
having a lot of Korean friends that I
can interact with I mean I've been
studying Korean for it's probably around
seven years now are there and studying
it I haven't been a hundred percent on
it all the time but that's been the
duration I would say that it's probably
within the past two years that I've
really felt more comfortable with that
right up after about five years of
reasonable efforts okay well that is
very encouraging because like my feeling
the three months is and I've been really
working hard at my career this might
various distractions I think I've moved
it forward a bit but it reminds me that
language learning takes time
yeah and therefore the key thing is to
really enjoy it and I think you enjoy
your Korean yeah I'm never disappointed
that at what I'm not able to do actually
quite pleased at what I am it and I
enjoy it yeah and with that I just keep
going exactly so and I will keep going
beyond the three months unless I get
distracted by some other lesson okay
Russian I know it's Russian as Russians
always they're not I mean I enjoy
Russian so much now yeah
and French and it's manage of Chinese
whatever yeah now I definitely uh I mean
I was saying to Kalina earlier to
iterate the same thing that for me I
mean I look at my Korean when I see you
know I can improve this this this of
this and this but at the same time I'm
not at all disappointed right now yeah I
look at you know in the effort that I've
put in my benefits that I've reached
from that the relationships the
experiences all the stuff that I've
gained from that has absolutely been
worth it and I want to continue to
improve but I don't look at it as you
know a discouraging like oh I'm still so
bad no I think of wow this this effort
that I put in has allowed me these
experiences that I never would have had
otherwise